so I have a question for the men and
your experience
who do you know know more men that have
been abused by women or women that have
been abused by men just anecdotally no
data let's go around uh if you mean why
do you mean not being hit or yeah
verbally yeah physically just let's
start physically I guess I know more men
have been hit by women yeah
more men that have been hit by women
I don't know what the statistics are but
in my own life
I have been hit by a woman attack I had
to call the police not that I couldn't
fight back but I chose to call the
police instead of do what I know my body
could do to preserve the situation and
prevent any arrest so I can say
firsthand in my own experience
that in my life there have been more
women attacking men what was
um did it come out of nowhere
no I saw it coming I was prepared okay
she had been out all night drinking with
her friends on a girls night out I was
home with the baby
oh
yeah the baby didn't want to go to sleep
because she just likes to stay up and
kick it with me and listen to music
four in the morning she shows up
I've known more women
but I've noticed that a lot of them
might be lying also lived in Sweden for
five years and there you kind of just to
them sexual abuse for example is just
some guy looking at them you know and in
Sweden like they say like it's it's like
the rape capital of Europe great and the
reason why excuse me sorry the reason
why is because apparently that's not me
saying anything but apparently a lot of
them are lying about it so I don't
really know
I've heard I've caught girls lying about
it though I've caught crows girls saying
that they've been beaten up and they
went to court and everything turns out
the guy was innocent so you never know
also us guys we don't what happens we
don't we tend not to address it as much
like we do yeah we'll be embarrassed
about it yeah it's it's you know I've
been in one situation it's a while ago
but
I didn't talk about it for years
and then someone was like I don't even
know that happened we don't you know
because we know if
you know the authorities get involved we
often look like the bad guy you know
even
because other women could be 100
important we look like the bad guy so
get another question though because
I would say it's me no go ahead um can I
ask a question because you know
I've never been hit by a girl and for me
the moment even looks like she might
the moment it even looks like she might
I'd be out there because I don't want to
put myself in a position where I feel
the need to hit the goal because I know
it won't end well so did you guys stay
in those situations or did you leave
because I don't I don't see how we can
back in end world for anyone bro it was
a wrap 30 seconds later it was over
after that like I mean once all the
emotions calm down you know there's
apologies or whatever like whatever the
issue is like there's no it doesn't end
well if it starts with you know throwing
fists you feel me so that's that's the
way that I saw it so you know those
apologies after that but I was kind of
like plus I'd sort of seen it
before with other people so I was I was
like that never ends well and I knew
even not fully understanding what I
wanted for me in a relationship I knew
that for sure that wasn't for me so I
was out was that a thing was there was
there like a switch because I've always
I've heard from guys where like the
girls will be super nice and then they
get either a kid or a commitment or
whatever they wanted there's just like a
switch in them and they go crazy yeah
well it what happened at that time was
um we went from being a couple to like
living together so like and it was
you know we had disagreements before so
like the it was it was gradual
escalation you know and then when it
goes to like goes to fists you're kind
of like what I know you do not just you
know it's little things like you know
like they take a swing or they throw
something or like that's how it kind of
starts so it's like little things and
you're kind of like that was weird and
you're kind of like yeah you ain't gonna
do nothing I think it's not a little
thing
is that what a thing in the us though
because I've noticed that a lot with
people from the US I mean you're all
from the US you know it's it's a funny
thing because
with with men we have that knowledge
that with any one of us if it was just
men of the room
we show a level a minimum level of
respect because we know that any one of
these guys could knock us flat even if
he's smaller than us even if he looks
dirty and like he ain't put together he
could probably knock us flat if he knew
how to fight we don't know so we respect
with women that threat is reduced
and there are women out there that will
take advantage of this fact
they will attack a man knowing that his
guard is down
and that he won't fight back especially
if he's a good guy yeah can I disagree
with you
of course please
um
I would agree with you only if like
statistically
um the statistics show that the level of
let's say DV
um in
um same-sex relationships so men and men
is just as high if not higher actually
so how how do you account for women
women and women have the highest DB
rates
and it's actually one-sided abuse more
women do it than men
but men and men is higher than
um men and women no women and women is
the highest oh yeah I'm not disputing
but men and men is still higher than um
men and women
no I I don't think oh you're saying men
and men and men so it goes women and
women and men and men yes and then
um heterosexual relationships so his
point was that men would um if men in a
room had a disagreement right and
correct me if I'm wrong
um they would see that okay maybe this
guy is a bit bigger than me so they
wouldn't confront it in that way whereas
women are given a pass so they know that
the man isn't gonna necessarily give
them I think it's more so heterosexual
yeah exactly now we're we're talking
about
men in a room that don't know each other
assuming that everyone is a heterosexual
male if just like tonight I came in I
didn't meet everybody I I just met
everybody tonight so I don't know what
everybody's sexual orientation is I
don't know what everybody's fighting
level is
I don't know if if I was to have you
know three of these cups and start
acting a fool I don't know which one of
y'all is going to take me out
so I I have to maintain a level of of
appropriateness
that with a woman
even if we're romantically involved
right if if I was with a dude
romantically
I would already know what his level of
fight is so I would know how far I could
take it with him but if I'd never if I
just walked into a room and I didn't
know who was in there I walk into a bar
I see those dudes at the bar I don't
know which one of those is going to be
the challenge for me so I have to be
careful and it's the same with me when I
go out interviewing people like the
women are way more Reckless whale
attacks
because like if I'm with a guy
and a girl starts acting crazy he's just
gonna pull her aside and tell her to
stop but if it's another dude like you
might get punched
like if another dude's acting aggressive
towards me there's going to be a group
of guys